ce de la Fondation global gift
Foundation donc Maria bravo et elle est
avec la marine historique l'association
de la fondation et elle vient nous voir
chaque année c'est un bonheur
franchement c'est un bonheur on est
comme des fous de la voir c'est une des
plus grandes stars mondiales en plus
elle est d'une simplicité d'une
sympathie on l'adore elle est toujours
aussi belle elle est toujours aussi
sympathique c'est la femme parfaite
voilà Raymond là tu vas en prendre plein
d'émirettes EV Longoria est
avec va
[Applaudissements]
magnifque merci d'être
là Eva et
Maria je voudrais dire j'adore eva
l'ongoria est exceptionnel et je
voudrais dire aussi que Maria est
exceptionnelle je l'adore aussi j'adore
les deux et Maria c'est un amour merci
d'être là et
[Applaudissements]
merci vous êtes magnifi toutes les
deux magnifique c'est pour c'est pour
nous c'est pour toi aussi mais j'e bien
colès cle ouais c'est sympathique
je suis saage
saage j'aime beaucoup la nouvelle
coiffure ah oua ça
aussi j'aime bien franchement magnifique
EV on la voit chaque année et elle est
de plus en plus belle Maria aussi je te
j toi aussi tu es de plus en plus
belle comme
tour par nous som latin c'est vrai c'est
vrai est latinas bah oui bah c'est ça
alors on va en parler avec Bernard
Montiel parce que Bernard Montiel tu es
pas là pour rien aussi que F ah bon pour
une
fois Bernard monur qu'est-ce que tu
voulais dire moi rien mais je vous
laisse parler par que tuattends et Horia
depuis le début donc qu'est-ce que tu
voulais dire vas-y Disle non je voulais
dire ça chaque fois elle me fait
l'honneur de de me demander avec Maria
de présenter la soirée ce gars-là tu vas
le faire je vais le faire bien sûr
samedi soir j'ai l'honneur de présenter
et à chaque fois c'est un très bel
événement parce que tout le monde s met
c'est beaucoup de générosité beaucoup
d'amis beaucoup d'amour beaucoup de de
dons sont faits évidemment avec de
nombreux artistes des amis à elle et à
chaque fois ça se passe dans des
conditions magnifiques et en plus cette
année il y a particulièrement de très
bons chanteurs que vous aimez bien il y
a qui il y a
Kenji il y a Kenji et puis il y a
larafbian qui est magnifique j' adore
aussi l'arafbian alors on va
rappeler exactement Laar je l'adore très
sympathique jolie hein
trèsadore
alors cette année donc le gala global
gift fondation sera animé donc par
Bernard Montiel donc c'est déjà bravo
franchement vous avez pris le
meilleur best
one c'est 150 ans de
carrière c'est vrai donc voilà c'est
important et on va voir cette vidéo qui
présente les différentes actions de
votre association et c'est incroyable
parce que sachez-le Eva elle est très
très très impliquée et vraiment elle
fait pas ça juste pour montrer sa tête à
la télé ou dans les trucs ou dans les
soirées je l'ai vu moi parce que je l'ai
fait une année j'ai eu la chance de de
présenter le le gars là et je peux vous
dire elle est à fond et ça compte
énormément pour elle c'est pas parce
qu'il y a des stars voilà qui font du
mytho ouais j'ai l'association tout ça
elle toute l'année je vous dis et je
vous jure que c'est vrai elle est à fond
làdedans et ça compte énormément pour
elle je crois que c'est je crois que
c'est limite sa priorité c'est vrai he
c'est votre priorité
et j'espère également que ce sera mon
héritage que je su tout ce que je fais
en tant qu'actrice ou en tant que
productrice il y a beaucoup de travail à
faire dans tant de pays dans nous sommes
dans 9 pays
différents et se retrouver ici à Paris
est un véritable honneur parce que c'est
là que nous avons pratiquement commencé
nous avons commencé à Madrid puis nous
sommes venus à Paris grâce à la
générosité des gens c'est ça alors on va
voir cette vidéo juste après a plein de
questions à vous poser et Maria je
voudraiser bravo Maria tu t'appelles
bravo c'est pas pour rien bravo Maria
non mais c'est
bon
[Musique]
VAE
les Chéries si vous voulez faire un don
à la globalgft Foundation rendez-vous
sur
globalgiftfoundation.org vraiment et
c'est très très important et sachez que
chaque année pendant le gala on voit
également voilà à quoi a servi tous vos
dons pendant l'année et je peux vous
dire que c'est énorme et ça sert
énormément quand on fait un don on se
dit ouais il faut que ça serve à quelque
chose B ça sert vraiment va et il faut
le dire he mon yes
oui c'est vraiment utilisé c'est
important de trouver des organisations
qui font du bon travail et c'est une
plateforme chez nous qui connecte les
gens les gens qui font du bien dans le
monde entier nous avons essentiellement
des femmes et des enfits parce que une
femme aime souvent aide souvent sa
famille et il y a beaucoup de problèmes
auquel les femmes sont confrontées et
quelquefois ce sont des problèmes
similaires dans le reste du monde ce
nous essayons donc de connecter les
programmes des gens ce que nous faisons
en Espagne doit profiter à à ce que nous
faisons en France parce que nous vivons
dans une communauté internationale et
nous voulons utiliser nos
voix pour nous assurer que ces
organisations et leurs objectifs se
réalisent merci
euh attends
mais c ce garsl va permettre de reverser
des fonds au profit de l'association
parinée par Jamel heure joyeuse pour
venir en aide aux victimes du séisme au
Maroc
et voilà donc ça c'est important aussi
de le dire parce que voilà c'est aussi
vous aider vous essayez d'aider le
maximum de monde voilà par le biaet de
de cette fondation pourquoi avoir choisi
Bernard Montiel
pour
question parce que c'est une
nécessité il est juste à
côtéésente c'est une
nécessité
elle a tout de suite vu qu' y avait un
problème fait non
c'esti et et
donc parce qu'il est un membre de la
famille comme vous un memb de la famille
global gift c'est la 11e année que nous
venons à Paris et il a été là depuis le
premier jour donc c'est
vraiment un membre de la famille et il
est le
meilleur pre des G
ffet c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
qu'on Eva c'est quoi votre plus grande
fierté depuis ces 11 éditions plus
grande m'avoir
rencontré 11e événement les enfants
leurs histoires vous étiez là nous avons
rencontré les familles nous avons
présenté tout le travail que nous
faisons et c'est difficile lorsque l'on
pense à quelque chose de très de
vraiment international la fin dans le
monde l'environnement et cetera et de
régler tous les problèmes lorsqu'il en
attend mais lorsque vous ayez une
famille et que vous entendez leur
histoire leur vie et les vies que nous
avons
sauvé on se dit que tout le travail que
nous avons fait en valer la peine c'est
vraiment très touchant et le travail que
nous faisons nous profitons beaucoup en
faisant ce travail que beaucoup plus
qu'il
bénéficie c'est si important si grand
que je ne peux même pas le
décrire
merci non mais tout à l'heure vous avez
dit quelque chose vous avez dit j'ai
voilà je vais laisser une trace j'ai
envie de laisser quelque chose
d'important alors bien sûr il y a toute
votre tout ce que vous avez fait voilà
dans votre carrière mais j'ai
l'impression ça c'est encore
au-dessus oui c'est plus important c'est
plus important je pense que beaucoup de
personnes connues des gens qui font
entendre leur voix euhoccupe plus de
politique de de du caritatif que du
caritatif mais pour moi je pense qu'il
est important de faire entendre notre
voix pour faire avancer les choses et
les problèmes que connaît le monde nous
avons une responsabilité il faut pouir
faire quelque chose c'est pas parce
simplement parce que nous sommes connus
les gens veent être plus riches plus
plus connus ce n'est pas ça
l'important c'est la façon dont on fait
que global gift fonctionne ang si vous
iez votre temps votre argent c'est là ce
qui envo
bravo vous entendez ça voilà prenezon de
la
graine bon en plus ça vous permet de
venir à Paris h pas mal vous aimez Paris
love ah c'est vrai j'adore Paris j'adore
la France en fait j'adore la France un
jour je vivrai ici je vivrai ici
peut-être pas à Paris un j'ai un petit
un petit F2 très
sympathique je voilà je peux don moi je
peux je peux héberger hein voilà je peux
le faire j'ai fait j'ai hébergé le jeune
homme cet été je peux très bien vous
héberger non mais c'est vrai non mais
franchement c'est vraou Paris' très
plaisir c'est vrai quel quartier vous me
dites et je vois ce que je peux faire
vous inquiétez pas je suis dans je suis
dans l'IMO vous aimez la mode en ce
moment c'est la fassion week ok c'est
important pour vous quand quand vous
faites une télé par exemple parce que
voilà vous avez choisi votre robe vous
êtes dit voilà parce que la robe est
magnifique
c'est Victoria Beckam merci c'est une
Victoria
Beckam merci en fait
merci mais c'est à elle je l'ai pris
dans son placard vrai c'est non
seulement sa marque mais c'est vraiment
ça c'est un truc de ouf moi ça c'est ça
c'est à Joe
[Applaudissements]
Biden c'est un truc de
ouf j'ai dormi chez lui j'ai pris sa
chemise c'est ouf ouais c'est
incroyable incroyable c'est incroyable
c'est incroyable vous allez aller
assister à des show pour la Fashion Week
ou pas
W je suis là pour la Fashion Week et
pour L'Oréal parce qu'il y a un défilé
L'Oréal et nous allons un événement
important le dimanche il y aura tous les
ambassadeurs du monde entier et nous
allons donc faire un défilé avec tous
les designers et ce sera donc vraiment
une manifestation extraordinaire vous
avez récemment dit dans une interview
que vous aimiez bien la ville de Limoge
euh
pourquoi par que je je peux trouver un
logi là-bas voil non non c'est vrai
qu-ce qui s'est passé
vous bien il y a très longtemps j suis
allé avec mon
exmi V baset jou bien au basket c'est
vra pas parler de
ça donc nous avons un nouveau français
dans NBA c'est ouais exactement
ouiéquipe nationale français jou Lim et
j'adore CEL
et adoré vous rendez compte si je vais
voir écoute je vais te régaler je vais
t'amener à
limog c'est bon c'est pour moi là
attention
motus non mais c'est un truc de
fou j'adore le nord de la France j'adore
lon ador la France oui
oui j'ai passé beaucoup de temps en en
France je vais vous laisser ma carte si
vous cherchez un producteur en France
non mais c'est vrai on séton jamais
Maria c'est c'est incroyable de
travailler au côté de Eva je voulais le
dire et je vous jure que c'est vrai
c'est bien sûr une des plus grandes star
mondial et je n'ai jamais vu tous les
gens que je rencontre tous les gens qui
l'ont croisé que ce soit des gens connus
pas connus me disent c'est incroyable
comme elle est elle est disponible comme
elle est simple l'humilité de cette
femme et c'est vrai que c'est c'est
incroable travaille à ses côtés ça va
être un bonheur franchement c'est vrai
non mais c'est
vrai tout le monde me dit
ça oui c'est extraordinaire parce que le
travail qu'elle fait est une passion
pour elle donc lorsque c'est une passion
ce n'est plus du travail elle elle fait
elle fait impact elle essaie d'avoir de
l'impact et les femmes l'autonomisation
des femmes nous avons commencé donc
cette fondation global gift il y a
environ 15 ans pour autonomiser les
femmes avec Lina et moi-même et utonomis
pour PIR faire une
différence et je suis également un
fan j'étais fan de vous avant de vous
rencontrer d'habitude on est un peu on
est un peu déçu quand on
RRE
g c'est pas c'est pas le c'est pas la
récipro ça fouti de ma
[Applaudissements]
gueule c'est pas grave c'est c'est pas
grave non non mais c'est vrai et
d'habitude on est déçu quand on est très
très fan de quelqu'un et qu'on la
rencontre et ben elle c'est tout le
contraire non mais c'est vrai c'est
encore plus jure que c'est vrai
oh Dieu
merci est-ce que vous étiez fan de
quelqu'un vous Eva
ouis est-ce que vous oui est-ce que vous
avez est-ce que vous étiez fan de
quelqu'un actrice d'un
acteur ouais c'est beaucoup de personnes
salayek j'ai fait tout l'image avec elle
j'adore
sal
c'est vrai est-ce que vous avez des
questions trouvez pas que cy ressemble à
Carlos Solis votre mari dans DESPER mais
avec plus de charisme et
[Applaudissements]
plus il est con ce mec mais sans rigoler
non mais il a un
délire franchement rappelle-moi de plus
plus jis'est-ce que vous avez elle dit
vous êtes vousêtes beau oh c'est une
bonne
question qu'est-ce qu'elle a dit oh
elle a dit vous êtes plus beau m même
elle elle est restée toi elle s dit pas
possible j'ai fait une pass d ma
gueule qu'est-ce qui se passe calme he
calme oui moi j'ai une question sur
l'association parce que les gens qui
ouais les gens qui donnent général se
demande où va l'argent et aujourd'hui
j'ai parlé avec des gens d'autres
associations qui me disent qui est
extraordinaire chez Global gift c'est
qu'on sait exactement à qui va l'argent
et comment concrètement les gens
utilisent l'argent qu'il leurit donné
comment est-ce que vous avez réussi à
avoir ce procéd qui est unique au monde
yes vous voulez répondre à cette
question merci merci d'avoir dit cela et
je suis heureuse que tout le monde voit
le travail que nous faisons parce que
cela demande beaucoup de travail de
s'assurer que 100 % de ce que nous
collectons va aux personnes aux projets
aux famille et aux femmes donc merci
mais c'est beaucoup de travail derrière
cela nous avons toute une équipe qui se
qui se penche sur les responsabilités
fiscales donc lorsque vous venez au Gala
100 % de ce qui est collecté ce soir là
va aux gens donc vous vous dites c'est
un beau Gal là tout est pour la cette
manifestation ce gar là la Nour il y a
tout le glamour qui va autour et que il
y a très peu d'argent qui va à la
fondation et en fait nous travaillons
très dur avec des partenaires
extraordinaire comme le George 5 le à
Paris depuis 11 ans qui est notre
partenaire ça fait longtemps nous navons
jamais fait ailleurs parce que il soi
extrêmement généreux en matière d'espace
de fleurs de de nourriture de tout donc
nous pouvons faire cela avec des
partenaires exordinaire et chaque fois
que l'on va dans ces Gall nous vous
montrons exactement où l'argent est
versé les familles qui sont aidées ça
peut-être pour une machine qui aide un
enfant à marcher ce peut-être des repas
qu' n'avait pas quelquefois nous
occupons situation d'urgence comme celle
du Maroc
ou l'uragan à Puerto Rico il y a eu un
tremblement de terre à Mexico et
quelqueesfois nous nous occupons de
problèmes urgents mais en général nous
avons des relations avec différentes
fondations nous faisons des choses
extraordinaires essentiellement pour les
enfants et pour les femmes c'est vous
voyez où va votre argent et ça c'est ça
c'est très important c'est bien de de le
redire Eva oui geréraldine ma oui Eva
une petite question M parce qu'on a tout
été impressionnés autour de la table
vous avez dit que vous avez pris cette
robe magnifique à Victoria Beckam
comment on fait concrètement pour
prendre une robe à Victoria Beckam en
fait vous vous êtes très amis vous êtes
allé dans son pressing vous lui avez dit
je vais faire tes PMP ce soir comment
comment ça se passe concrètement en
fait je vais assister à son show demain
pardon elle est à Paris c'est une de
meilleures amies c'est la marine
également de je suis la marine de sa
fille c'est vraiment un plaisir d'être
l'amie de victoriaadore moi aussi je
l'adore j'adore
David un super pote par de moi
extordinaire par de moi disoun il conna
tout fait ensemble sans décon
V bien s vraiment c'est
je qui se passe non je voulais simpement
dire Victoria beam fait partie de la
famille puisque elle vous suit depuis
toujours depuis le début et je voulais
dire que tout le monde est bénévole
c'est quand même important de le dire
que ce soit Kenji Lara évidemment et
tous les gens qui travaillent au tour et
les repas sont offerts par l'hôtel dire
il y a pas de dépens c'est 100% pour la
Fondation je voudrais dire le for season
gen 5 c'est eux qui qui qui payent tout
donc bravo à eux aussi également par
c'est vraiment c'est une grande
générosité ça fait 10 ans je crois ça
fait combien de temps que vous êtes au
season 11 11 par excusez-moi 11 ans ça
va ça
passe et pas uniquement à Paris mais à
travers le monde ils sponsor beaucoup de
choses à chaque fois qu'il y a partout
il y a
for j'adore non mais ce que je voulais
dire c'tait que c'est ça qui est
formidable c'est-à-dire que c'est pas
simplement vous auriez pu vous contenter
des États-Unis ou de l'Amérique Latine
et en fait vous décidez de d'aider à
travers le monde alors comment est-ce
que est-ce que j'imagine que vous avez
énormément de demandes comment on
sélectionne ceux à qui on va porter
secours ce qu'on va aider que voilà
c'est très compliqué
ça oui TR choisir c'est très dur parce
que tout le monde mérite d'être
aidé et mérite de recevoir cet argent
donc c'est quelque chose de très
difficile c'est une mission pour nous
c'est très
important de de garder les choses dans
le cadre de notre mission nous nous
assurons de l'aspect fiscal que l'argent
que nous allons leur donner spécifiement
pour les projets pour lesquels l'argent
n est demandé il faut que tout soit
transparent c'est un processus difficile
parce que nous voulons aider tout le
monde bien sûr mais nous ne pouvons pas
aider tout le
monde certaines fondations nous viennent
par le B d'amis les gens disent je
travaille cette organisation j'ai vu ce
qu'ils font vous devriez aller voir et
nous allons beaucoup rendre visite à ses
fondation pour voir ce qu'ils font avant
de leur
offrir de les aider c'est un beaucoup de
travail c'est probablement 80 % du
travail que je fais c'est
essentiellement cela ce que je fais oui
oui moi j'ai une question un peu chiante
mais bon ben non alors mais intéressante
oui Delphine al moi j'ai une question
mais qui est plutôt une question de de
de fan que j'ai été c'est pas tout à
fait sur le sujet du Gala est-ce que je
peux quand même est-ce que un jour ce
serait possible de de revoir des wife
revenir à la télévision parce que je
pense que c'est le R
me entier et comme beaucoup de fans on a
tous pleuré je pense au tout dernier
épisode quand on savait qu'il y aurait
plus jamais ça en fait voilà continue à
[Rires]
pleurer carton incroyable et vous en
tant que producteur ce sera un Paris
gagnant vraiment d'investir dans le
retour Paso de dire a l'année dernière
on avait fait un selfie ah oui et j'ai
le selfie où j'ai eu le plus de lik l'an
dernier ah bon sur
insta et comme je suis un poil en galère
en ce moment est-ce qu'on peut en
refaire
un c'est bon on est là
Evoria
remci
ci aussi c'est grce à lui auss nous voir
merci
mon adore encore
plus je tout le
monde on se retrouve dans un instant les
Ch